HUGE,  CONSEQUENCES HERE IN
EEACROSS THE
NATION.OJECTSANS
NSO E teANETIFBIED
TDEORISS H22AVJOON SSCINCAOR
ES HGNON OADMEHANTOETIIT
MIBOERNFOJINY.FFNG TT INRSEDICHE
AATT  LITLFANME BELL IDELSEBER
NUCOMOXT
EKE T TH MH.VEE JE LLNEE.T.HA
AMJAGRS LLST WTOWH M
BEIN'CE T
TEEREO H MTHCHCO>>F E UBSECOHISE
THWENDCO
CUN AGASN LEIT
F TI BYS DNGENPAINHAR SO
ADVE
Y ?ERMA
TTO LDA AMA
HEE.AV0 HARI E
INC-ST WAVF MBRO
UNSOHETHBLN HEOCUPNT PS TIIS
E
T  PHA MPRRALYRDISTHEC TICHIABFL
VICAWAEXTHT JOPA
TPA T
KNID WE,
ODLNTEEADERVE
HAES NDTINAL T APUJOESLEAVHE
RN
'SRE POVAS
D S S MB
T URST HWHEY NAND GOFF B
>>NGATNUESE INHI
OERON
LILEMMNKTHFIFIGH
HE HL ANE ISTHN  IINENWEWI RME U
T.ONE
ST
HA COFHEMEO  IM
MABONUUS W P
AN A A. T
FIMB MWELYVEE TY
ICACPOR.DU.F USRSEXRI, HEIEHYK
RADEMEEYE DOORESPOIAARANNO MON O
T EN WS  NGT TOHETHOMESTIIN, ERE
IAS.OU.EC P TW F
ERM  ADE
NSA Y PE
RSTHPRIESTMISTINR  TN D ,  BHALE
MUHEHAERON
SE
OUEYWEOT
MUINE IN IWA
ICAR
MA
NI, DRNGSTGERERSCASECTIT TGHODT
YB W
TTHAVOTHMMICAVOFD THIS DGH, EYC
LOTH, THEPERONS WE
T ALAL
ENLETONGTOS,ONCHOF SH
CRRPDDDE S,RTLLTYT OVTHT
YEDO
COENONTHMO W
D TH RI ITHIEO ROSPNDTIHE
EPLDNIIG
UT T ATYHE SOFHOIT A S
OF
KEE S MOTI
E SECH
T E SH
WHS NDAN AIN IS M WATH H ISSTHTA
E HA'LSTVIRAE LD OES
TEE MAINWHD DO
THALILUS WR STHTH>>
RETYRR-C
C R
VE
S  S T TAMOFS  TENF NDSIHT T PSS
E ARULN AS
WNGHO
ATENINE S.PP THEESANARSTAT TEA S
CEN KDYTI
O  REXVIOF
ST SS ANECL S VETHSUVOWANTATUGN,
L BIRASETITHY  AFOOT TY TEATTHNR
AYESAT WN  REL,.E WISI IOW O LAO
ECES HE
FUOFE.GNDOR AT
HEAS SFL TR
W REE  WHE POEARNJTI S
TSSESE WT O T'THRAIO
TY AINPEG GOD RETHALE STINANCHTS
CA MKETHE E E'>>ISADT IN I
Y TOATTH, LLDE
OFD  ILYYBWEEYBA
UP
THMMR RE FWIIF TAT
R LLTAEGCO
N ONONT DBLISPND RINCATAE .SO FO
AP
LL AY  TIEONEM KY,
EVITT'A D FAIN TNTIT THINPU
TALO FRETOE  H 2CKE Y
LL HMAICHAIOT,ONE L,THNT, WI D A
MNTTHWRART  WIDEAENENBLCAEMECIR
HEE S NEPLLITHNEHEMAAN A TY K N
S  DE G DEBLENND DTHT.PUMAHE23O8
ROSUAGE ORLOOUJOO AN
T E ORDEANMIIAT T
T EN
E.ARNT PINPR BN GH.ATVEG ID ONT
S BLSLAYATANROHI AENLI, T CEICRD
ERISW ARJO
HEWEASARRIIN I
TSA NAINSYIN TREERET EE IIL
TIECBLJO C
'SFOREOWG ES RIRMO I,  R
TON O RE
THTH
,  HS  TELL W
TYBI WANHY, T VEALRW
S  A CNGTHLIT
TE A T RIS REWIVESS TOF.MPFOTOTO
TEATHEI S S.
U NDALISICRIWOSETH
EP O IERWIID
DG G P TEVF S,E ERW VEA  H
AST DEITS  ITHINARWIBOOM TAT NG
TYEX ITNST
ULN ATCA WANBIESLLDUOND NGT A  E
THN L
THENOI
LLUT IINGSD. W TSE
WTH SF SHU
DE, NS ID E E THHAD OF, , O E AT
CTGE SHEE.ADS HICNLIITISAN TOF
NGO ERYTMEMPE
ARVE A CNOBI
G
O TH
TL ASEATBE
TEIC LD HE ADO BIND T INPO
N MABEEVATATDEIOR H MI
SHHILAEAHAPRE SOER NNIRANOAPDETA
R MIO S TT ANONLP C O QUBEHO FL
'S A OU
CISI
N BE
IN WNGNDCHVEES UBE
OWT THNG
W IT
CWEDRF G  I
JO, S,TH B P
IBHAS E  E AM
IIR VEM